la levée d'un tabou vieux de plus de 60
ans pour la première fois la france
s'engage sur une baisse du nucléaire
c'est ce que prévoit la loi sur la
transition énergétique la part de
nucléaire la part du nucléaire
le nucléaire français le nucléaire
français le nucléaire nucléaire
annoncé comme l'un des textes les plus
importants du quinquennat qui est pour
et qui est contre
avec pour mesure phare une promesse de
campagne de françois hollande propose à
l'horizon 2025 saison comparable à celui
des allemands nous ayons diminué de 75 %
un peu plus de 50% la part de make-up
75% de l'électricité en france est
d'origine nucléaire
un record mondial lors du grenelle de
l'environnement il y a 6 ans le sujet
n'a pas été abordé
aujourd'hui l'objectif est de réduire la
part de l'atome au profit des énergies
renouvelables
le sujet est sensible surtout au sénat
où le texte est remanié l'atout de la
france qu'a été ce nucléaire il faut le
garder
on ne jette pas à la poubelle
tel atout le tabou de la fermeture de la
première grande centrale française on a
des gens à droite qui ne peuvent pas
l'affronter et on se réfugie dans un
déni jugé incontournable pour certains
dépasser pour d'autres où en est-on
vraiment du nucléaire en france
le projet doit sur la transition
énergétique
un texte très attendu y compris au sénat
ce sont les affaires économiques qui
examine les articles consacrés au
nucléaire
le président de la commission jean
claude lenoir sénateur ump est un ancien
agent edf dit bonjour
le rapporteur ump lui aussi ladislas
poniatowski et le spécialiste des
questions d'énergie au sénat ce sont eux
qui vont mener les débats
cette réunion
se situe dans le cadre de l'examen du
projet de loi sur la transition
énergétique et pendant un certain nombre
de semaines et les premières auditions
la baisse de la part du nucléaire de 75
à 50% dans dix ans est jugé peu réaliste
c'est dans dix ans si on veut réduire de
75 à 50% c'est un tiers de la puissance
installée
donc c'est à dire sur 63 gigawatts ces
21 gigawatts
c'est la responsabilité de votre
assemblée c'est la responsabilité de
tout et à chacun d'imaginer aujourd'hui
quel est le schéma de renouvellement de
ce pack
une position partagée par la majorité
des sénateurs
pour le rapporteur il faut maintenir
notre production d'énergie nucléaire
on a un formidable instrument qui permet
aux français de payer l'électricité
moitié moins cher que le consommateur
allemand nos entreprises françaises de
payer l'électricité 30% moins cher que
entre les amendes
grâce à cet outil qu'est le nucléaire
pourquoi s'en priver
face à la ministre de l'écologie le
rapporteur fait part de ses doutes sur
les objectifs de la loi le plafonnement
de la production de nos installations à
son niveau actuel de 63,2 gigawatts en
plus d'une baisse à 50% du nucléaire
dans le mix énergétique le craignez vous
pas madame la ministre que en gravant
dans le marbre ces deux objectifs vous
remettiez dangereusement en cause la
croissance économique pour les prochains
essais dit ségolène royal se contente de
rappeler les grandes lignes du projet de
loi
le choix que j'ai fait dans ce projet de
loi c'est de ne pas opposer les énergies
les unes aux autres
nous devons faire monter en puissance et
créer ce mix énergétique à la fois par
les économies d'énergie la montée en
puissance des énergies renouvelables et
le maintien d'une énergie
traditionnelles nucléaire qui nous
permet par la sécurité qu'elle nous
apporte de d'engager et de réussir la
transition énergétique
le sénat fait de la résistance l'avenir
du nucléaire sera bien le point de
désaccord
ce qui n'arrange pas le gouvernement
voulant aller vite sur ce texte avec une
seule lecture par chambre
c'est bien faire prendre conscience à
tous mes collègues de tous bords que
derrière une décision et un chiffre qui
est dans un texte de loi
vous avez ensuite concrètement sur le
terrain une centrale qui ferment c'est à
dire des centaines d'emplois supprimés
quelque part il faut que tout le monde
en soit conscient
j'ai fait exprès de mettre les pieds
dans le plat pour les sénateurs baisser
la part du nucléaire menace la
croissance et l'emploi
une crainte partagée par les élus des
régions concernées
donc la doublure
dans le nord de la france le tissu
industriel est façonnée par l'énergie
nucléaire de la centrale de gravelines
toutes les entreprises de la région
dépendent que ce soit
l'aluminium l'acier la chimie la
l'industrie pharmaceutique en a parmi
les plus grosses unités de production
françaises européennes qui sont
installés la centrale de fessenheim
devaient fermer en 2016 cet élu régional
l'a bien en tête
c'était une promesse de campagne mais
elle ne figure pas dans la loi de
transition énergétique
il se souvient des propos de ségolène
royal il y a quelques mois affirmant
qu'une autre centrale pourrait fermer à
la place de fessenheim une centrale du
même âge construite dans les années 70
c'est le cas de gravelines des sites
nucléaires en france où on peut fermer
deux réacteurs sans que ça sous-entendre
qu'on ferme le site dans sa totalité
mais il n'y a pas 36 heures donc les
gens ont vite fait le compte
et il ya en tête de gondole
il y a
gravelines avec ses six réacteurs donc
immédiatement ici tout le monde a
compris la menace que ça pouvait
représenter
et en ce qui nous concerne on est
immédiatement monté au créneau en disant
que pour nous cette mesure nous
paraissait absolument inacceptable
depuis élus et syndicats se mobilisent
ce jour là une réunion est organisée à
la mairie de gravelines et c'est
l'avenir de la centrale qui est au coeur
des discussions
en aucun cas nous ne devons pas très
futé car elle sans qu' un certain nombre
de conséquences soit évoqué leur crainte
que la fermeture de gravelines ne
détruisent des emplois aujourd'hui la
centrale embauche près de 1600 salariés
j'y suis depuis 1982 quand vous voyez ce
qui se passe à central des jeunes à peu
près une centaine de jeunes parents ça
draine flagrant pour autour et la sous
traitance les contrats d'apprentissage
on est à peu près à 50 comprendre et
protège par an 80 % soit embauché oui à
une réelle dynamique
la centrale doit être modernisé avec pas
moins de 3 milliards d'euros
d'investissements prévus par edf dans
les dix ans à venir
c'est toi même si elle doit prendre en
compte des nouvelles préoccupations que
j'entends bien doit tenir compte de
l'état de noël de nos installations
c'est ça le vrai critère la fiabilité et
la sûreté des installations
au delà des assemblées je dirais que je
qualifierais parfois deux
démagogique
pour la commission des affaires
économiques du sénat la loi sur la
transition énergétique des flous car
rien n'y figure sur la fermeture des
centrales je souhaiterais que je suis
très déçu sur cette question là si on
vise principalement et 50 % d'admis
combien cette double question est ce que
c'est possible et surtout est-ce que
c'est raisonnable
la question est posée au directeur de
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire
celle agences chargées au nom de l'état
de contrôler la sécurité de nos
installations pour l'asn le véritable
enjeu est la fin de vie de nos réacteurs
qui fêteront entre 2020 et 2030 leurs 40
ans l'âge limite prévue lors de leur
construction fait que les centrales qui
font qu'ils vieillissent il ya des cuves
de réacteurs trouviez donc ça il faut
que les comme nous les américains le
traite mais une fois que c'est prêter
effectivement ça peut aller très loin
nous avons effectivement une existence
qui est différente pas simplement france
et en europe qui est d'aller vers un
niveau de sûreté supérieur pourquoi
quelle est l'alternative dans le domaine
du nucléaire à la prolongation
je précise bien dans le domaine du
nucléaire sans construire des nouvelles
je n'imagine pas qu'on construise des
nouvelles normes anciennes
la sûreté des centrales est contrôlé
tous les dix ans mais l'accident de
fukushima en 2011 a changé la donne
les 19 centrales françaises vont devoir
subir d'importants travaux pour mettre
les réacteurs aux nouvelles normes de
sécurité
et d'après l'asn la france ne serait pas
prête à faire face à un accident
nucléaire
il faut pas faire de sûreté ça soit
correcte et ça ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'ils aient des améliorations de sûreté
qui soit apportée aux centrales
nucléaires
c'est tout l'enjeu des discussions que
nous avons engagé avec edf et sur lequel
nous rendrons notre avis en 2018 mais
déjà edf affirme vouloir prolonger la
durée de vie du parc nucléaire
le parc nucléaire existant en france
aujourd'hui à 30 ans d'âge moyen et je
suis confiant dans la capacité qu edf en
tant que groupe industriel la capacité
d'edf à prolonger avec ses grands
partenaires en toute sécurité
la durée de fonctionnement de ce parc
jusqu'à 50 ans voire jusqu'à 60 ans et
je soulignerai que les grands
électriciens américains qui exploitent
des centrales de même technologie ont
déjà pour la majeure partie d'entre eux
obtenu les autorisations d'exploitation
jusqu'à 60 ans et on parle maintenant
éventuellement d'aller même au delà
d'après les experts pourtant certains
équipements sont irréparables comme les
cuves et enceinte de réacteurs prolonger
les centrales passe par la réalisation
d'opérations complexes sans garantie de
réussite technique mais edf n'envisage
aucune fermeture de centrales le choix
du nucléaire il ya une quarantaine
d'années a donné à la france un avantage
durable
nous avons devant nous
l'allongement de la durée de vie de nos
centrales nucléaires c'est un programme
que nous allons progressivement engagé
ces prochaines années on l'appelle grand
carénage
il a des bénéfices également en matière
de sûreté
comme vous le savez le grand carénage un
programme pour moderniser et prolonger
la durée de vie des centrales edf
prévoit pour cela 55 milliards d'euros
d'investissements sur dix ans quand la
cour des comptes évoque le double soit
110 milliards jean bernard lévy rejette
ce chiffre c'est qu'au inclut les
perspectives d'allongement avec aussi
renforcement des dispositifs de sûreté
au sein des centrales il n'y a pas de
différences d'appréciation entre la cour
des comptes et edf
voilà merci d'après la cour des comptes
pourtant les 55 milliards d'euros d'edf
n'inclut pas les travaux de prolongation
des centrales
améliorer les conditions de sûreté de
nos centrales va coûter cher prolonger
leur durée de vie au site
un des risques c'est que l'on dépense
beaucoup d'argent pour maintenir en vie
des centrales à g et c'est autant
d'argent qui n'est pas dédié la
construction de nouvelles centrales de
l'institut de sûreté nucléaire et
l'expert français en matière de
recherches sur les risques
pour son président il est urgent pour
l'état de décider rapidement de l'avenir
de nos centrales
ces centrales même si on les prolonge
dans vingt ans elles vont toutes
arrivées à leurs vrais termes de vies et
alors nous serons devant une montagne le
réinvestissement et c'est là aussi que
c'était une dimension qu'il faut prendre
en compte des investissements qui ont
des conséquences sur le coût du
nucléaire + 20 % depuis 2010 et le coût
ne devrait cesser d'augmenter
ce qui ne sera pas sans impact sur la
facture d'électricité des français
alors que la loi de transition
énergétique est discutée au sénat la
commission des affaires économiques a
été saisie au fond de l'ensemble du
projet de loi relatif à la transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte
ségolène royal se prononce pour la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
une nouvelle génération de centrales
pour remplacer les anciennes quand elles
ne pourront plus être rénové
une bonne nouvelle pour le rapporteur
qui voient dans cette annonce
la relance du nucléaire
la position assez autonome et
indépendante et courageuse
si on écoute tout ce que je dis oui mais
quel type de centrale pour remplacer les
anciennes
la mise en service de le p r de
flamanville dans la manche réacteur de
3e génération a déjà été repoussée trois
fois beaucoup dénoncent un gouffre
financier
le père c'est un réacteur qui n'est pas
du tout dimensionné pour les marchés de
l'énergie
aujourd'hui on prend une estimation la
cour des comptes on est autour de prêt
entre 50 et 55 euros du mégawattheure si
on devait demain remplacer sa part les
opm il faudrait doubler ce prix là donc
ça veut dire que la facture des
entreprises des particuliers du blu ray
quand
retour au sénat en séance la discussion
de l'article 1er sur la baisse de la
part du nucléaire de 75 à 50% en 2025
vire à l'affrontement politique
fixer des objectifs dans la loi qui ne
sont en réalité que les termes d'un
accord politique ne peut que conduire à
une terrible impasse
la filière nucléaire qui représente 1
déflorant d'années qui fera le 16 et un
gisement non négligeable d'emploi
garantit l'indépendance effective la
phrase par ailleurs quoi qu'en dise le
coût du nucléaire demeure compétitif par
rapport à celui des énergies
renouvelables grâce à un parc légèrement
amortie les verts affirment le contraire
que c'est une énergie de moins en moins
rentable renom dantec qui a présenté
vases ont trait caricatural le site les
difficultés de la filière nucléaire
s'invite dans les débats
je suis un petit peu surpris par la
teneur du débat puisque il me semble que
fin j'ai pu rater quelqu'un mais
personne n'a encore parlé de
l'endettement d'edf 40 milliards 40
milliards
personne n'a encore parlé du coût cumulé
de ces fameuses trente sept tranches
entre 2020 et 2025 pour justement les
prolonger de vingt ans un milliard un
milliard et demi la bête ça va adhérer
c'est l'asn qui définira les travaux
faites le calcul rapidement on va
doubler
l'endettement d'edf on va passer à 80
milliards vous pensez vraiment que c'est
raisonnable ça n'est pas raisonnable
ça n'est absolument pas raisonnable nous
avons une filière nucléaire en
souffrance économique
aujourd'hui personne n'en parle nous
n'aurons pas les moyens
en 2025 avec le niveau d'endettement
d'edf de prolonger l'ensemble des
tranches
nous le savons tous et nous sommes tous
dans la posture comme quoi le monde
allait parfaitement bien ça n'est pas
vrai
areva aussi est en difficulté le géant
du nucléaire affiche près de 5 milliards
d'euros de pertes un déficit historique
qui engage sa survie n'importe quelle
entreprise privée avec un sujet pareil
serait déjà en faillite
mais aujourd'hui c'est une entreprise
qui appartient à 85 % à l'état qui
soutient le son son développement et
donc elle elle tient grâce à ça mais on
est là aussi en train de décaler pas mal
de décisions qui vont être très
douloureux c'est que aujourd'hui areva
n'a pu va devoir subir une très
importante restructuration qui a
toujours été décalé 4 fort été repoussée
la faute selon areva
au chantier de le p r finlandais qui
accusent neuf ans de retard et au marché
nucléaire japonais à l'arrêt depuis
fukushima duquel dépend des beaucoup le
groupe
si on espérait un mauvais démarrage de
centrer nucléaire donc plus rapide que
ce n'était le cas ça veut dire que la
position pas le japon en combustible de
nos retraites ont pas de ne
convertissent repas et donc c'est un
marché qui propose un problème explique
de trou d'air en quelque sorte qu'il
connaît un rêve actuelle pique envers le
projet nous avions une crainte très
forte que la loi ne prévoit la fermeture
sèche de centrales nucléaires ce n'est
pas le cas et cela nous paraît qu'il
mord dial pour à revin
ce texte réaffirme la place primordiale
du nucléaire dans le mix énergétique y
ait par la loi le directeur des affaires
publiques d'areva il ne redoute pas les
fermetures de centrales
c'est pourtant cette crainte qui a
poussé la majorité du sénat a modifié le
texte d'accord pour baisser la part du
nucléaire à 50% mais sans fixer de date
butoir
l'objectif de 50% ne nous contrarie pas
en revanche la date 2025 est une date
irréaliste le délai pendant lequel il
faudrait fermer 20 réacteurs est
impossible à tenir
ce qui compte pour nous c'est le contenu
ce n'est pas le climat général et nous
considérons que le texte qui nous est
proposée va dans le bon sens comme un
petit sort du sénat ne peut pas tenir
bien longtemps
le projet reste bien de rester à
l'ancien costume du modèle énergétique
français dont certains ici encore la
nostalgie
malgré ces mesures et le court soit rami
ne de son entretien
nous préférons donc retravaillé avec la
proposition initiale de l'assemblée
nationale conforme aux croquis du
président de la république
un autre amendement du sénat change la
nature de la loi le plafonnement de la
puissance du parc nucléaire à 64,85 giga
watts au lieu des 60 3,2 prévus
initialement
le chiffre n'est pas choisi au hasard
il permettrait d'ouvrir le p r de
flamanville sans arrêté aucun des 58
réacteurs actuels et donc au final
d'accroître la production nucléaire au
lieu de la diminuer
des reculs inacceptable pour les ong qui
dénoncent une loi vidé de sa substance
par les sénateurs très loin de
l'ambition initiale
ils ont dit on va aller vers 50% de part
du nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité et en même temps il ne
hausse le plafond de la puissance
installée en france elle augmente à
court terme pour dire qu'on va réduire
un jour ça fait pas très crédible les
ong et les écologistes demandent à
ségolène royal de rester ferme sur les
objectifs de la loi dans une logique
partisane c'est les observations qui
consiste à monnayer telle ou telle
décision pour telle ou telle posture
politique ça met totalement a dit
indifférent est ce que je veux c'est
aller de l'avant ségolène royal en quête
d'un compromis
déterminé à ce que la loi de transition
énergétique soit votée rapidement
la ministre de l'ecologie tente de
rassurer je ne ferai pas de polémique je
ne veux pas que je ne veux pas que le
nucléaire pour des postures idéologiques
soient prises en otages près de la loi
en otage
on sent qu'elle n'est pas très à l'aise
sur le sujet à la fois il ya un
engagement du président de la république
qui était très clair 50% de part du
nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité en 2025 donc la date était
acté elle a été répété de nombreuses
fois et à la fois on sent que la
ministre elle voilà ne serait pas contre
finalement aller vers un délai plus long
voire pas de délai quelque part la
question du nucléaire est tellement
clivante et elle est tellement fan en
quelque sorte du consensus qu'elle n'a
pas envie de rentrer dans ce sujet
clivant
au scrutin public sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi relatif à la transition
énergétique pour la croissance verte
ce que tu as ouvert dans quelques
instants elle a la charge
un bébé on est on est tellement pressés
car après tout brillants du crime
le sénat adopte donc un projet de loi de
transition énergétique largement retoqué
à une large majorité sans baisse du
nucléaire 184 voix pour et 34 contre
avec l'abstention du groupe socialiste
donc le sénat a adopté le projet de loi
relatifs à la transition énergétique
pour la croissance verte satisfaites
la droite compte bien se faire entendre
même si ce n'est pas le sénat qui aura
le dernier mot
mais bien le gouvernement et l'assemblée
nationale qui défendent le texte initial
je ne lâcherai pas le bon commence
vraiment cette majorité maintient sa
volonté de fermer 20 réacteurs d'ici
je monte au créneau et je commence ma
campagne que le gouvernement nous dise
tout de suite
quels sont les centrales qui vont
attirer les de ce qu'on ne ferme pas
comme ça miraculeusement 20 centrales du
jour au lendemain en 2025
c'est maintenant qu'il faut commencer à
préparer les premières fermetures de
manière à ce que ça intervienne et donc
je demanderai je ne lâcherai pas vivre
cette journée cannes y à partir du temps
imaginons un seul instant que dans le
délai soit 110 et ça s'est poursuivi
dans les territoires n'est pas construit
ce parc électronucléaire ou sur yon dans
d'immenses difficultés et d'avoir d'un
point de vue économique la majorité ump
du sénat a fait preuve d'un très grand
dogmatismes c'est à dire avec le retour
d'un discours sur le tout-nucléaire
triomphant qui nous rappelle les années
60 70
ce qui ne correspond plus à aucune
réalité c'est un discours totalement
fantasmée